what has culture been doing to us well
here's a tweet from outkick I don't
watch Saturday Night Live so I did see
this on the Twitter instead of Comedy
SNL Embraces full-blown activism a
non-binary cast member appeared on
Weekend Update last night to advocate
for gender transitions for minors well
ladles and jelly spoons we've got video
of the purported comedy show Saturday
Night Live uh doing just that I was
going to say Enjoy but I don't see how
you're going to be able to
since we started this year over 400
anti-lgbtq bills have been introduced
across the country many of which
directly Target trans youth here to talk
about it is someone with their own
introduction
s
first non-binary cast member it's Molly
[Applause]
made it thank you Mr Che Molly what is
all this well as you know I've been
wanting to come to update and talk about
trans people but I have for a much
longer time than that wanted to fly down
from the ceiling listen to that Michael
yeah restricting healthcare for kids for
some reason there's something about the
word trans that makes people forget the
word kids if you don't care about trans
kids lives it means you don't care about
freaking kids lives wow
you know at one point I heard a crew guy
say is she gonna die up there and then
another guy was like you mean are they
going to die up there
and then they both walked away and
didn't help
which feels a lot like how trans people
are being treated right now
hey Mr J am I still in the frame I mean
your feet are
treasure
yeah
Body Party everybody
uh
NPC non-playable character that's what
everyone in that audience applauding
they don't even know what they're
applauding there's nothing funny about
it by the way this woman she's a woman I
don't care if she identifies as
non-binary I'm not even sure what that
means and she can go about her life
living however she wishes but everyone
watching that knows she's a chick right
she's a chick
she's a low-grade Melissa McCarthy
that's all but she is a woman so if she
identifies as a man and a woman that
okay go do that but why are you pushing
this stuff on kids once again of course
the host there he uh intros the segment
and intros her by saying that there are
more than 400 anti-lgbt bills I mean
there's just no such thing there are
bills that are trying to protect youth
from having their genitals chopped off
which is something that we all would
have agreed on 10 years ago by the way
at this point I think it's fair to say
that if you are pro-trans when it comes
to kids meaning you are for them going
on hormone blockers and having their
breasts cut off and all the rest of it
you're actually anti-gay so it's not
anti-lgbt because a certain set of these
kids will just turn out to be gay kids
meaning it is a young girl
who's probably a tomboy and maybe would
grow up maybe is the key part would grow
up just to be a lesbian an old-fashioned
rugby playing Ellen DeGeneres style
lesbian or it might be an effeminate gay
boy who might grow up to be hopefully a
functional adult gay man and you are the
ones that are that are literally abusing
them literally
[Music]